think they want to win at least two out of three
they make it a 500 stretch it's not better but
it's going to be tough this one here and then
the two against the Penguins and here come the
Devils moving in Michael MCL dropping it back the
shot and they score Alexander Holtz a wicked wrer
beats heart and the Devils have the lead just 3
minutes and 10 seconds in sanheim gets caught up
ice and because of that forwards are trying to
defend and watch Holz here a little drag around
the Stick of Cam York and a perfectly Place shot
to the upper portion of the net he can rip it he's
a talented player Devil's this fire turn the puck
over here's tippet he'll fire save rebound it was
there for connect but jabbed away and now he was
the other way looking for tley broken up chop back
through and the Flyers have it and here's Cur
rumbling in his shot muted and then the stick
save by Schmid yor ahead cier for forer Forster
beats his man moves to the middle gets checked
the puck bouncing around a shot by Couer and the
save by Schmid gotted it away but connected gets
it back to York and then Cura down L sanim whips
it in on goal from the angle Schmid ready for that
now the puck out and suddenly it's a two-on-one
to Foley and Jack Hughes Jack Hughes the shot he
scores Flyers have the Devils pinned in their
zone for a long time can't capitalize comes
back into the flyer Zone and it's in the
net two nothing Devil's courtesy of Jack
Hughes the Flyers where they spent time in
the offensive zone and eventually York gets
caught down low and catua is the one that
ends up being back I mean this is what you
don't want I mean a forward having to
defend as the Flyers continue to press
offensively the kept in is Luke H will send it
down low the pass goes goes across ice ja hu's
out for Tooley the big blast is blocked by York
bounces back out shot Heir save heart couldn't
control the rebound another save and then York
tries to clear and does all the way down it they
did an absolute amazing job great block by York
initially then a scrambly play here and look at
the left pad of Carter har bouncing high in
the air spotted by heer his third game back
after missing significant time with injury got
that pass to Brad his shot blocked then Jack
uses there heart makes the save and it's dug Loose
by rist thean hard up the glass that skips ahead
pass forer he doubles get the puck back once more
back Hugh SW theod gives it up here's brink brink
to the puck Brink steps it and the save made by
SPID now Brink has it back tried to duck under
the check of Smith but was taken off the Pu BS
it ahead Holtz touch pass moud thecloud makes
the move onto M Cuts in save heart the puck box
the around play it right back up to force knock
down pliers get it back so forc for four connect
the touch passier and now Walker once again up on
the play drop back the big blast by connect they
went off with the stick and then blast and now
that's a two-on one it's Hughes moving up with
Mercer Hughes weight so drops it back and the
club save from hard on to Foley played by Cloud
out to the point doesn't get there it's tipped
out to Center by Owen Tipp it he's going to get
to the puck Tipp it cutting on in Schmid able to
make the save and smother it and luk Hughes is
back that's and that's good news for you hate
to see anybody get injured good to see him back
here's tippet cutting it in the back hry didn't
get all of it SPID knocked it down there is a
penalty though the arm is up cross to the hash
marks back out York takes a look other way shot
for through the save by smidth that back on the
wall Forester is there to York one timer safe SP
rebound Frost scor it's a power play goal fires
within one shooting the puck find Forester on
that off Wing able to one time it from there you
can retrieve Puck when you retrieve Puck then
you can break down defenses and that's exactly
what happens York quickly to the net WI a puck
net front and Morgan front picks up the Loose
Change and the Flyers are one goal away from
tying this thing [Music] up there's Corner in
rebound h d stop by spectacular Carter har on
the save one or two of the saves he made there
that one up a toley and then Holtz still one goal
[Music] game swer to the right Wing back across
ice Miller holds fire save heart rebound batted
around fand on they don't clear it Miller cross
ice and they get set back up and here's Lazar
back to hols in front goes all the way through
back out big shot Miller tag saved by har Puck
goes off of stealer comes out in front shot save
har stop McLoud Puck batted high in the air fers
need to get control here cross we finally play
it across to Walker Devils wi another draw Holtz
the Hues pass off the Mark goes into the corner
he recovers it pass comes back out to luk Hughes
and now Jack with some room into the slot shot
save Hart rebound to Foley he scores Hart made
the save couldn't control the rebound and then
the Flyers couldn't take care of business in front
it's a power play goal in the devil's lead three
to one So eventually they're going to burn you
and they're just too much talent too many options
watch eer in front here I don't know what happened
he kind of just fell to the ice but har not able
to tie up that rebound and that's the most
frustrating thing for a goal turn is when you're
trying to freeze the puck and it kind of squirts
away from you now sealer in got it down low the
back out of sa rebound and somehow shid got across
comes back out in front Atkinson jamming away and
now paling after it you get it back out to Walker
Walker a shot ainson might have had a better
chance or he was but didn't consider himself in
a great shooting position now ainson has the butt
back out Walker with a shot save smid rebound back
header and the save Again by Schmid needle pretty
low right now for the pliers that dig really deep
to try to find some offense Neville doing a fine
job checking as well here's connect to Cura back
out it goes Walker quick shot SC Walker says why
not and it beat Schmid and the Flyers are still
alive it's a three2 game we're getting toward
the late stages of this period and you don't want
to pass up any shots and Walker is very good at
getting pucks through carals it off the wall from
cier not an easy play he's on his offside gets it
from his backand to his forehand actually keeps it
on his forehand but able to Corral what holds on
Waits looks flings and it's batted away for thir
break into the final minute thir period 8 seconds
remaining on the power play lton holds nothing
there gives to brink brink back to lton one Turner
[Applause] score forer may have gotten his sck on
it the fires have tied it at three with 50 seconds
to go there is your comeback so you got to find
ways to retrieve pucks the Flyers do it Forester
who had been in the one-time position for much of
the power play changed spots went to the middle
of the ice and he gets a stick on this onetime by
Lon deflects it down and through the five hole of
Schmid who set rce he goes into the
devil Zone FTS it off for sanheim in
front Ariel not handle by Cur
and it's big trouble the other
way Luke and Jack moving up Jack with
a puck Jack to Luke and the game is
over Luke Hughes wins it in overtime two
onone to Perfection four three or final
the Devils win it tailored for this three
Onre hockey it's Jack and Luke Hughes and
the Miss and that sends transition the
other way and boy what a pass there by
jacku I mean you talk about threading
the needle beautiful sauce pass oh